fighting is brown doubled and trapped
Grant Williams
good for him and now he's having words
in the Earl Jimmy Butler
Williams defends Butler a bump the grind
the gyration and the two in the foul and
they're having worse
[Applause]
and he's cut or no
after that three by Grant Williams he
was having words with Jimmy Butler on
the way down
here's the dish by Brown and here's the
shot made by Williams and look at the
words
already Williams and Jimmy Butler are
smiling about it and then here's the
contact at the ensuing play
and let's go head to head guys
thank you I agree thank you this is the
way it should thank you let's compete
you are one step away from the ultimate
goal of being in the NBA finals double
text just put his head down against
Grant Williams and got all the way to
the cup
[Music]
and then here's the answer by Williams
not known for this
not known for putting the ball on the
floor but certainly can do it this